The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
We also saw,
or we tried to understand what
the free energy actually was.
And we said that when you have,
for example,
an exothermic reaction,
that not all of that energy
released is going to be released
in a form that can do useful
work.
Some of that energy that is
released, some of that delta H,
for example,
goes into, or can go into the
vibrations and rotations of the
product molecules,
that energy of which is not
able to do useful work.
And so the amount of energy
that we can actually use to do
work is this free energy,
is delta G right here.
So it can be something less
than delta H.
We also saw a condition,
which was the oxidation of
glucose, where delta G was
actually greater than delta H.
And that is the case where we
have some of that internal
energy locked up in the
reactants which now is released
in the form of this useful work
delta G.
And I think we had just started
to talk about this term delta S,
which is the change in the
entropy for the reaction.
And we talked about how to
calculate it.
We calculate it from the
absolute entropies of the
reactants and the products.
Delta S for a reaction then is
the absolute entropy of each one
of a product.
Times the appropriate
stoichiometric number summed
over all the products.
And then minus the absolute
entropy of each one of the
reactants times that appropriate
stoichiometric number summed
over all the reactants.
And it is the difference
between the two,
delta S for the chemical
reaction.
And S is an absolute entropy
that is a result of the third
law of thermodynamics,
which I mentioned,
I think, last time.
You will talk about it a lot in
detail in 5.60.
Let's look at an example here
at the change in entropy.
Because I want to show you that
you can have a change in entropy
that is large enough to make an
endothermic reaction
spontaneous.
You can have what we call an
entropy-driven reaction.
For example,
the melting of ice.
To melt ice,
to go from the solid form of
water to the liquid form,
that is an endothermic
reaction, 6.95 kilojoules per
mole.
However, going from the solid
form of water to the liquid form
there is a great increase there
in the entropy,
in the disorder.
And it is that increase in the
disorder that allows that
reaction to be spontaneous.
We can calculate the entropy
change for that reaction.
That entropy change then is the
absolute entry of the product,
which is liquid water,
minus the absolute entropy of
the reactant,
which is solid water.
And you can see that delta S
here is positive.
Is there a question I can help
you out with?
Did you have a question?
Can I help you out?
Okay.
That delta S is positive.
We have increased the disorder
of the system.
And it is that positive delta
S, then, that gives us a delta G
that is negative,
meaning our reaction in this
direction from solid to the
liquid is a spontaneous
reaction.
Delta G here is delta H,
6.95 minus the temperature at
which the reaction is proceeding
times that change in the
entropy.
And, in this case here,
delta G now is minus 1.57
kilojoules.
That reaction is spontaneous,
even though it is endothermic.
And it is that increase in the
entropy that is driving this
reaction here.
Now, I want you also to notice
something right here.
And that is that the change in
the entropy usually is in units
of joules per degree Kelvin
mole.
Delta H, just about always,
is in units of kilojoules per
mole.
Remember when you're working
with delta H,
bells ought to go off in your
head.
Remember that you probably have
to do a unit conversation here
from joules to kilojoules.
This catches a lot of students
on an exam, so I am trying to
give you some fair warning about
this.
Now, what I want to talk about
is this free energy of
formation, delta G sub
f nought.
The Gibbs free energy of
formation is analogous to the
enthalpy of formation.
This is what we looked at the
last time.
The Gibbs free energy of
formation, delta G sub f,
our nought for our standard
state, which is one pressure,
is the free energy formation of
one mole of a compound from its
elements in their most stable
form at the standard state.
It is analogous to the heat of
formation, only it's the free
energy of formation.
It is tabulated for you just
like the enthalpy of formation
is.
You can look up the free energy
of formation for every compound
that is known.
However, unlike the enthalpy of
formation here,
the free energy of formation
you can also calculate.
You can calculate from this
expression, delta G equals delta
H minus T delta S.
If you've got a reaction for
which you have defined the free
energy of formation,
so if you know the free energy
of formation of a molecule and
you know the delta S for the
reaction that defines that
enthalpy of formation,
then you can calculate the free
energy of formation for every
molecule, which is different
from the enthalpy of formation.
That you do have to look up,
but you can actually calculate
the free energy of formation
given that you know the enthalpy
of formation and given that you
know delta S for the reaction
that defines that enthalpy of
formation.
Questions on that?
OK.
But why is this free energy of
formation so important?
Well, that's what we have got
to look at right now.
Here is a reaction that
produces one mole of carbon
dioxide.
The delta G for this reaction
is minus 394 kilojoules per
mole.
The delta G for this reaction
is defined as the free energy of
formation for CO two.
Why?
Because this reaction,
as written, produces one mole
of CO two from the elements that
compose CO two --
But the elements in their most
stable form.
The elements are carbon.
And the most stable form of
carbon is graphite.
And the element is oxygen.
NO two is the most
stable form of oxygen at one bar
pressure and our room
temperature which we are working
with here.
That is the free energy of
formation of CO two.
And this is very important
because that free energy of
formation of a molecule defines
the molecule's stability
relative to decomposition to its
elements.
For example,
the forward direction here,
this delta G is negative.
It is spontaneous in the
forward direction.
When delta G of formation is
negative for a molecule,
what we say is that the
molecule is thermodynamically
stable relative to its elements.
Because the formation of that
molecule, that delta G is
negative.
The reaction as spontaneous is
written in the forward
direction.
It is not spontaneous in the
reverse direction.
The reverse direction,
this delta G would be positive.
So because the delta G for this
reaction is negative,
we say that CO two is
thermodynamically stable
relative to decomposition to its
elements, carbon and oxygen.
This is important.
The sign of the free energy of
formation for a molecule is
important.
Had the free energy of
formation of CO two been
positive, we would have said
that was thermodynamically
unstable relative to
decomposition to its elements.
Because this forward reaction,
delta G would have been
positive, but the reverse
reaction would have been
negative.
Reverse reaction,
there would be a spontaneous
tendency for CO two to
decompose.
But this is an example where CO
two is stable relative to
decomposition to its elements.
Here is an example of a
molecule where it is
thermodynamically unstable
relative to decomposition to its
elements, benzene.
I write a reaction here that is
the formation of one mole of
benzene from the elements in the
most stable form.
The free energy of formation of
a mole of benzene here is
positive, 124 kilojoules per
mole.
It is positive.
What does that mean?
Well, it means that the reverse
reaction, delta G,
is negative.
It means that benzene has a
thermodynamic tendency to
decompose into its elements.
It is unstable relative to
decomposition into its elements
because it has a positive delta
G.
It is the reverse reaction that
is spontaneous.
But even though a reverse
reaction may be spontaneous,
it can also be really pretty
slow.
When was the last time you saw
a pint of benzene decompose to
graphite and hydrogen?
Not recently.
And so even though you have a
thermodynamic tendency to
decompose, it doesn't mean that
the rate is going to be fast
enough for you to see that in
any reasonable amount of time.
There is a thermodynamic effect
and there is a kinetic effect,
and you are going to talk about
the kinetic effect in much more
detail with Professor Drennan a
few weeks from now.
But, at the moment right here,
we've got two different names
to talk about,
thermodynamic stability and
kinetic stability,
so to speak.
And that is the following.
We call a molecule stable or
unstable.
And when we use those terms,
stable and unstable,
we are referring to the delta G
of formation.
We are referring to the
thermodynamic tendency of the
molecule to decompose.
So benzene here is
thermodynamically unstable with
respect to decomposition to its
elements.
However, benzene is what we
call nonlabile.
These terms,
labile and nonlabile,
refer to the rate with which
that thermodynamic tendency is
realized.
Because the rate of
decomposition is so slow such
that you never see it,
we say benzene is nonlabile.
Nonlabile means it is not going
to decompose.
Not because it doesn't have the
thermodynamic tendency to,
but because the rate is just
too slow.
However, if benzene's rate for
decomposition was very fast,
we would call it a labile
molecule.
But it is not.
It is nonlabile,
but it is unstable.
Unstable refers to
thermodynamic tendency.
Labile and nonlabile refers to
the kinetic, the rate at which
that thermodynamic tendency is
realized.
Well, like the enthalpy of
formation, delta H sub f,
like that, delta G sub f,
the free energy of formation,
well, that can also be zero.
For example,
for the elements hydrogen,
oxygen, chlorine,
xenon, all those gases,
free energy of formation is
zero.
Just the same way in which we
described it last time for the
enthalpy of formation.
For the elements bromine here
and mercury in the liquid form,
delta G sub f,
free energy of formation is
equal to zero.
For the elements carbon in the
form of graphite,
sodium, iron,
iodine, all solids,
their free energy of formation
is also equal to zero.
Because those are the elements
in their most stable form at our
standard state.
However, look at this.
The free energy of formation of
bromine in the gas phase,
that is not equal to zero.
It is not equal to zero because
bromine in the gas phase is not
the most stable form of bromine
at our standard state.
Liquid bromine is.
Delta G of formation of bromine
in the gas phase is not zero.
Likewise, here the free energy
of formation of diamond,
that is not zero,
because diamond is not the most
stable form of the element
carbon at one bar pressure at
room temperature.
Graphite is.
It is important to look at the
phase of the elements that you
are dealing with.
Do you want to calculate delta
G for a reaction?
Well, just like calculating
delta H for the reaction,
you can use the free energy of
formation.
You need to know the free
energy of formation for every
one of the products,
multiply that by the
appropriate stoichiometric
number and sum that all up.
And then you do the same here
for the reactants.
You need to know the free
energy of formation for every
single one of the reactants,
multiplied by the
stoichiometric number,
sum that all up and take the
difference, and you will have
the free energy for that
chemical reaction.
Notice this is products minus
reactants.
Just like calculating
enthalpies from the heats of
formation, that was products
minus reactants.
However, when we calculated
enthalpies from bond enthalpies,
that was reactants minus
products.
That is something you do have
to know.
Likewise, you can also
calculate delta G for a reaction
now from knowing delta H for
that reaction and also knowing
delta S for that reaction.
You've got your choice,
to use the free energies of
formation that you can look up
or from knowing the enthalpy for
a reaction and knowing the
entropy for that reaction,
you can calculate delta G.
You've got your choice with
delta G here,
depending on what information
you're given or know.
Now what we want to talk about
is our ability or inability to
control the spontaneity of some
chemical reaction to control it
by virtue of adjusting the
temperature.
Let's take this example here.
This is sodium bicarbonate,
better known as baking soda.
This is what you put into the
dough of some kind of baked
goods that you want to make,
muffins or cakes.
You put it in there in order to
lighten the batter.
And, of course,
the way this works is that the
sodium bicarbonate decomposes.
It decomposes to form CO two
and water.
And when it decomposes it does
so in the oven and the CO two
and the water then expand,
they evaporate,
but in that dough they kind of
make bubbles before they totally
evaporate.
And around those gas bubbles
the dough kind of hardens a
little bit and eventually the CO
two and water are driven off.
But what it leaves behind is a
very porous structure in the
dough.
It leaves you something that
you can actually put your teeth
into.
Have you ever tried putting
your teeth into some cake where
somebody left out the sodium
bicarbonate?
It is an interesting
experience.
I have done it.
Important here.
But this is a reaction that is
very endothermic,
plus 136 kilojoules per mole.
It is, however,
a reaction where there is an
increase in the entropy.
We're increasing the entropy a
lot here, increasing the
disorder.
And let's calculate delta G for
this reaction.
Well, delta G for this reaction
at room temperature is plus 36
kilojoules per mole.
It is non-spontaneous.
You know what?
That is good because you don't
want that reaction to start when
the dough batter is still
sitting on the kitchen counter
because at that point you are
not going to be able to harden
the dough in any way.
But let's try to make this
reaction now spontaneous by
increasing the temperature.
Let's make this term here
negative, more in absolute
value.
We want to make this term
larger than delta H so that we
can have a negative delta G.
Well, we can do that by raising
the temperature to a baking
temperature, 350 Fahrenheit,
which is about 450 degrees
Kelvin.
Now, when we calculate delta G
at 450 degrees Kelvin,
what we find is that delta G is
now negative.
And now we've got a spontaneous
reaction.
Now, when you get up to this
baking temperature,
this reaction proceeds readily
in the forward direction.
We have adjusted the
spontaneity of this particular
reaction by increasing the
temperature, by making this
second term, the T times delta
S, by making that larger in
absolute magnitude than delta H.
We have made that reaction
spontaneous.
There are reactions for which
we can control the spontaneity
by adjusting the temperature.
And let's take a look at that.
Well, as you know here,
delta G is the linear function
of the temperature.
Let me just draw a dependence.
And, actually,
this is for the decomposition
of sodium bicarbonate.
Let me just draw delta G as a
function of the temperature.
The slope of this line here is
minus delta S for that reaction.
You can see that.
This is going to be the slope.
I am plotting it versus T.
The intercept is delta H.
It is the enthalpy change for
this reaction.
And now let me just draw a zero
here, a dotted line.
I drew that zero because I want
you to see that at some
temperature right here,
that I am going to label T star,
that delta G is equal
to zero.
What that means is that at this
temperature the sign of delta G
is changing.
You can see that for
temperatures less than T star,
the value of delta G nought
here is greater than zero,
meaning the reaction is
non-spontaneous.
For temperatures greater than T
star right in here,
you see that delta G nought is
less than zero.
It means we have a spontaneous
reaction.
We have controlled the
spontaneity of this reaction by
the use of temperature.
Let's calculate the value of
the temperature at which the
spontaneity of this reaction
changes.
Let's do that.
To do that, we are going to set
delta G nought here equal to
zero,
and then we are just going to
solve for T star.
We are going to solve for that
value of T star,
that for this delta H and that
delta S, will make delta G
nought equal to zero.
Let's do that.
Well, then T star is delta H
over delta S.
If I plug in for the
decomposition of sodium
bicarbonate, the delta H and the
delta S, then T star is 406
degrees Kelvin.
So your sodium bicarbonate is
not going to decompose until you
get to this temperature.
At least for this reaction,
it appears we can control the
spontaneity of this chemical
reaction.
And that is the case.
In general, if you have a
reaction that is endothermic,
that is delta H is greater than
zero, and if that reaction
increases in entropy,
delta S is greater than zero,
that reaction will be
spontaneous for temperatures
greater than some temperature T
star.
You can see that by the signs
of the reactions here.
If delta H up here is positive
and delta S is positive,
then you've got to increase
this second term,
T delta S, the absolute
magnitude of it enough so that
it is larger than delta H.
And you are subtracting the
two, well, that is when you are
going to get the delta G
negative.
For large enough temperatures
the delta G will be negative.
But suppose we have a reaction
that is exothermic,
delta H is less than zero,
and a reaction that decreases
the entropy, delta S is less
than zero.
I plotted that now as a
function of the temperature.
And you can see that the slope
of this line has changed.
We now have this positive
slope.
Well, in this particular case
you are going to have a
spontaneous reaction whenever
the temperature is less than
some temperature T star.
Because right here,
that is our T star.
And so for temperatures less
than that, delta G is negative.
For temperatures greater than
that, delta G is positive.
Again, you can see that.
If delta H is less than zero,
this delta H will be negative.
And delta S here is going to be
negative.
We are going to have a negative
times a negative.
That is a positive.
And so, since delta H is
negative, T is going to have to
be small.
This is going to be a positive
term.
T is going to have to be small
so that in absolute value it is
not larger than delta H in order
to get a negative delta G.
However, suppose we have a
reaction that is exothermic,
delta H less than zero,
and delta S is greater than
zero.
We are increasing the entropy
here.
Well, this is the best of all
worlds.
When you have an exothermic
reaction that increases the
entropy, this reaction is
spontaneous at all temperatures.
Delta G is going to be negative
for all temperatures.
Because delta H is negative.
And then you have minus T delta
S.
Well, delta S is positive.
So you have a negative number
plus a negative number,
or a negative number minus a
positive number,
delta G is always negative.
Spontaneous at every
temperature for those reactions.
You cannot control the
spontaneity of the reaction.
And then, finally,
you can have a situation where
you have an endothermic
reaction, delta H greater than
zero.
And the worst of all cases,
delta S less than zero.
You are decreasing the entropy.
You are making the system more
ordered.
In that case,
you have a reaction that is
never spontaneous.
Again, you can see it from the
sign.
If delta H is positive and
delta S here is negative,
a negative times a negative is
a positive, so we have a
positive number plus a positive
number, delta G is positive at
all temperatures.
So with temperature there we
also cannot adjust the
spontaneity.
This is very important to
understand.
Now, what we have been talking
about so far is delta G's that
have been delta G nought's.
We have been talking about
delta G's, free energies of
formation in our standard state
of one bar pressure.
What that means,
for delta G nought,
what that means is that
the partial pressures of your
reactants and your products,
they are all one bar.
Delta G nought for a reaction
is the free energy change for
that reaction when there is one
atmosphere of each,
or one bar of each of the
products and the reactants.
Let's take this famous
reaction, argon plus boron going
to carbon plus deuterium,
A plus B, C to D.
This delta G nought,
here, is a delta G for a
reaction under the conditions of
one bar partial pressure for D,
one bar partial pressure for C,
one bar partial pressure for B,
one bar partial pressure for A.
That is what that means.
But, you know what,
that's not the situation you
usually have.
Say, for example,
you are going to start this
reaction.
You start the reaction with one
bar of A and one bar of B.
But, of course,
you don't have any C or D yet
because you haven't run the
reaction.
What we've got to be able to do
is to calculate delta G for
conditions which aren't at the
standard state,
which aren't at one bar D,
one bar C, one bar B,
one bar A.
We've got to be able to do
that.
And the way you do that is
represented here by this
expression.
Where this expression came from
is again a subject of great
interest in 5.60.
You will see where this
expression comes from when you
take 5.60, but right now we are
going to use it.
This is going to allow us to
calculate delta G from knowing
the standard state delta G
nought.
It is going to allow us to
calculate delta G for the
reactants and products at any
given pressure.
You see this is delta G equals
delta G nought plus RT ln
of the following.
This has the partial pressure
of product C divided by a
reference pressure raised to the
appropriate stoichiometric
number.
And that is multiplied by the
partial pressure of the product
D divided by a reference
pressured raised to the
appropriate stoichiometric
number.
And that is all over the
partial pressure of A divided by
a reference pressure raised to
that appropriate stoichiometric
number times the partial
pressure of the other reactant
over some reference pressure
raised to the appropriate
stoichiometric number.
That ratio is something that we
call a reaction quotient.
We call it Q.
It is the ratio of
instantaneous partial pressures.
We might be running a reaction,
and at any time the reaction
may not be complete.
At any time we could stop the
reaction.
We can figure out or measure
what the partial pressures of
reactants and products are.
And we can calculate what this
Q is knowing what those are from
a measurement.
That is what the reaction
quotient is.
Now, our reference pressure is
going to be one bar.
What I am going to do,
and what you can do in this
reaction quotient,
is that I am going to put
P(rf), the reference pressure as
ones in here.
And so I am not going to
explicitly write it out.
And that is just fine,
as long as you put the
pressures then,
here, in units of bar.
So this is the reaction
quotient, the form of it that we
are going to use,
as long as you put the
pressures here in units of bar.
We've got to remember this
because I am now going to use
this in a very interesting way.
This is going to give me delta
G at any arbitrary pressures of
the reactants and the products.
How am I going to use this?
I am going to start to talk
about the equilibrium constant
for the reaction.
I've got my famous A plus B
going to C plus D reaction.
And you already know that all
reactions have some kind of
equilibrium.
There is a forward reaction and
there is a reverse reaction.
And we know that,
as we said, delta G is less is
zero.
If delta G were less than zero
for this reaction as written,
then it is the forward reaction
that is spontaneous.
If delta G is greater than zero
for the reaction as written,
then it is the reverse reaction
that is spontaneous.
And now, here comes the really
important point,
and that is if delta G is equal
to zero for that reaction as
written then we are at chemical
equilibrium.
When delta G is equal to zero,
then we are at equilibrium.
Notice this is not delta G
nought equal zero.
This is delta G equals zero.
That is what defines chemical
equilibrium, when that delta G
that I just showed you is equal
to zero.
Here is that expression again
that I showed you.
Delta G is delta G knot plus RT
ln of this reaction quotient.
What I am saying is that
we are at equilibrium when this
delta G here,
this one is equal to zero.
Not that one.
This one.
If that is the case --
If you are at equilibrium,
then I can take this equation
here, and what I am going to do
is move delta G nought to this
side, and the result is delta G
nought is equal to minus RT ln
of this reaction quotient.
See where I am going?
Delta G was equal to zero.
That let me then solve for
delta G nought is equal to minus
RT ln of this reaction quotient.
Now, under this condition,
when delta G is equal to zero,
this reaction quotient Q has a
special name.
And that special name is a
thermodynamic equilibrium
constant.
When we are at equilibrium,
this reaction quotient is that
equilibrium constant K.
This defines the equilibrium
constant.
What the equilibrium constant
tells us is about the relative
proportions here of the products
to the reactants.
If the equilibrium is large,
we've got a lot of products.
The numerator has got to be
large relative to the reactants.
If the equilibrium constant is
small, well, then we've got few
products relative to the
reactants.
The quotient,
Q, that reaction quotient,
is equal to the equilibrium
constant when delta G is equal
to zero.
Not delta G nought.
And so that is where this
expression comes from.
Delta G nought is equal to
minus RT times the log of the
equilibrium constant. If
you know delta G nought for a
reaction, you can figure out the
equilibrium constant.
If you know the equilibrium
constant by knowing,
say, the partial pressures
present of the products and the
reactants at equilibrium,
you can work backwards and get
delta G nought.
Now what we are going to do is
rearrange these equations here a
little bit.
We are going to rearrange them
in a form so that it will be
easy to tell whether or not
you're at chemical equilibrium.
We are going to use this
reaction quotient,
Q, as a measure of whether or
not we are at chemical
equilibrium.
We are going to compare Q to K.
When Q is equal to K,
we are at equilibrium.
Remember what Q is.
Q is the ratio of the
instantaneous partial pressures
of the products to the reactants
at any time during the reaction.
K is the ratio of the
equilibrium partial pressures of
the products to the reactants.
Now we are going to work on a
formalism that is going to allow
us to easily compare Q to K,
so that we can tell whether or
not we're at chemical
equilibrium.
Let's do that.
Here is the expression that I
wrote earlier that allowed me to
calculate delta G at any
arbitrary pressures for the
products and the reactants.
Here is the expression that I
got when delta G was zero when
we were at equilibrium.
And then delta G is equal to
minus RT ln of K.
What I am going to do right now
is I am going to take this and
substitute it in.
Let's do that.
I am going to substitute this
into this more general form.
When I do that,
I am going to get minus RT ln
of K plus RT ln of Q.
This is just a simple
substitution.
But now what do I have?
I have the difference between
two logs.
I have a minus ln(K) here plus
an ln(Q) here.
The difference between logs is
the log of that quotient of the
arguments of those logs.
So I have RT times ln of
Q over K.
This is the difference in the
logs.
That is then the log of the
quotient of the arguments of
those logs.
This is going to be great,
here, because look at what we
are going to be able to do.
Remember what Q is,
the ratio of instantaneous
partial pressures.
And you know what K is.
The ratio of partial pressure
at equilibrium.
Bottom line here is the
following.
If Q is less than K,
what that means is we don't
have enough products formed
compared to what we should have
at equilibrium.
That is, when Q is less than K,
we haven't got enough products
compared to what we need for
chemical equilibrium.
If Q is less than K,
well, then up here in this
expression for delta G we have
the log of a number smaller than
one.
The log of a number smaller
than one is going to be
negative.
If Q is less than K,
then our delta G is going to be
negative.
And notice, this is delta G,
not delta G knot.
If our delta G is negative,
then the reaction is going to
be spontaneous in that forward
direction.
On the other hand,
if we've got a situation where
Q is greater than K.
That is, where we have more
products than what equilibrium
says we should have.
Well, in that case,
Q over K is going to be a
number greater than one.
And the log of a number greater
than one is always going to be
positive.
And so our delta G for the
reaction as written is going to
be greater than zero.
And so the forward reaction is
not spontaneous,
but the reverse reaction is
spontaneous.
And what is going to happen is
that the chemical reaction will
proceed in the reverse
direction.
It will use up all of those
extra products that we had for
whatever reason to try to attain
equilibrium.
Here is another way to look at
it.
I am going to plot here Q
versus the time of a reaction.
And we know when Q is equal to
K, we are at chemical
equilibrium.
Suppose we start in a
condition, some time t equal
zero, where Q is less than K.
If Q is less than K what that
says is that we don't have
enough products compared to what
we need for chemical
equilibrium.
When Q is less than K the
reaction is going to proceed in
the forward direction.
It is going to make the
products so that we can attain
equilibrium, so we can make
enough products so that we get Q
is equal to K.
The reaction will proceed in
the forward direction.
If, however,
we start in a situation where Q
is greater than K,
that means we've got too many
products compared to what our
chemical equilibrium says we
should have.
And so what is going to happen
is that the reverse reaction is
going to proceed.
It is going to use up those
products and form more reactants
so that it can attain the
equilibrium value for the
partial pressures of the
products and the reactants.
Q is going to be our measure of
whether or not a reaction is at
chemical equilibrium.
Very important.
Questions?
R is the gas constant.
It is something that will be
given to you,
you can look up.
Other questions?
Okay.
See you later this week.